were you able to identify any genes that
responded differently in the small
groups versus the large
groups yeah so in our paper we do an RNA
seek so we look at the RNA of these
embryos um and essentially what I do is
I have a large group of 300 embryos and
a smaller group of 100 embryos so we're
comparing the group sizes of both
treated and untreated individuals for
the purpose of the paper we focus on um
the two group sizes that are being
treated and what we see is that there's
a to of like 16 genes that are up and
down regulated um and there's specific
um types of Pathways that are being used
in the small groups and specific types
of Pathways being used in the large
groups so that almost indicates that if
you're in a large group you're coping
with the stress in one way versus when
you're in a uh in a smaller group you're
coping with the stress in a different
way